foreign
[Music]
Dr volkoff it is lovely to see you thank
you for making the time to be on the
show thanks for being here Tim it's a
pleasure thanks for having me absolutely
and I wanted to say before we launch
into the full conversation
a sincere thanks to you in the entire
Nida team because I have
found addiction to be very near and dear
to me in the sense that my uncle died of
alcohol-induced cardiomyopathy one of my
aunts died of alcohol and Percocet as an
overdose one of my best friends growing
up died of a fentanyl overdose so this
is a subject that I think not
surprisingly to anyone listening is
incredibly important and I've just had
the opportunity to see it in very close
quarters so I want to start with just
thanking you for doing the work that you
do so that's that's step number one
and
I thought then I would take a very hard
left turn and ask you about cadavers
specifically I read that you when you
were quite young asked your father if
you could bring a cadaver home to
dissect his answer was yes and that his
answer was generally yes to anything
science related could you just flesh
this story out a little bit provide a
little more context absolutely and first
of all I'm sorry for the loss of your
family relatives and your friend I mean
it is very tragic and that's why I mean
I'm so devoted to the whole subject
because it's it shouldn't be I mean
people shouldn't be dying from
addictions and and yet they do and there
are many factors that if we could change
then we wouldn't be losing these lives
so let me jump into the question that
you call left side or right sided my
father is a scientist and so he was
obsessed of having his daughters Kitty
and have a son so he was obsessed of
having the daughters going to science
and I was the one that I have another
sister who was then in high school but I
was the one in medical school and I
wanted to do research and I was
absolutely fascinated by the human body
and anatomy and I I just marvel about
the beauty of how our bodies are
constructed so in the classes we have to
take anatomy and we work hard to dissect
actually
basically the section on people who have
died on corpses but I didn't have enough
time and I wanted I'm very obsessive
whenever I do things I do them
compulsively so I I wanted to be able to
do that right and and based on the time
limits that we have at school it was
going to be impossible we would be able
to each one of us this SEC for example
one extremity and so I asked my father
if I could bring
a corpse that I could do out of sea and
my father had a laboratory in the house
so
and he said yes but then my mother and
my sisters Rebel and I said if Nora
brings a corpse into the house for her
Anatomy classes then we're leaving the
house
that was very categorical I lost that's
it no more
so I'm gonna come back to the the
obsessive
focus and following the trail where it
leads I'm going to come back to that but
before I do perhaps you could just
describe where you grew up where you
were at the time and how someone or a
family with the last name volkov which
to most people would perhaps
bring up connotations of certain types
of Origins end up in where you ended up
in terms of
your formative years
I was in Mexico City I was born in
Mexico City I went to medical school in
Mexico City and it was until I was
finishing medical school that I left
Mexico to go to Paris then to the jungle
and then I went to New York for my
training in Psychiatry and the reason
why actually I ultimately was born in
Mexico City it's it's interesting it's
it's driven by I always say the
belligerent nature of of men because my
father
is the grandson of Leon trosky and the
only place that gave political Asylum to
leontrovsky was Mexico
and my mother who was born in Madrid
ended up in Mexico because also Mexico
was the place that gave Asylum to the
children
of
the people that were fighting against
Franco in Madrid so Madrid was going to
be bombarded by the Franco forces so the
government of Mexico in an attempt to
save those children offer Asylum to the
children to be brought from Madrid into
Mexico the care of the Mexican
Government and so that's how the two
families came together my father came to
Mexico as an orphan because androsky
basically had taken the responsibility
of him his mother had committed suicide
his father had been sent to a
concentration camp
by Stalin and so the only relative that
he had was Trotsky so he came to Mexico
because that was his family and he was
12 years old when he came to Mexico and
that's how he ended up in Mexico my
mother came to Mexico when she was 18
years of age coming with her family to
look for her two brothers who had
comments little children as part of the
Asylum to the the children that were in
Madrid
and they met and that's how fortuitous
histories they met they fell in love and
then they had four daughters and I was
the second one of them and and we
actually lived in the house where
Trotsky had been killed
because my father took the
responsibility to ensure that the house
were Trotsky live will be left as a
museum so that there would be a
historical memory of what tyranny can do
the tyranny of staling and basically the
extermination of all of his enemies
which of course Trotsky was of his one
of his main ones and he had
basically aim to destroy the family of
Trotsky up to the third generation which
we could have ended with my father but I
it would have ended up with us actually
the third generation is us and they
tried to kill my father and my father
was a little child but they didn't
succeed so and then then by my time I
was born which is the third generation
no one has tried to kill me 40 days
later not from The Styling era but I
shouldn't be so sleepant about it I mean
it's a very serious issue and and of
course it has follow our family and at
one point when I was a medical student I
wanted to go to Russia to study because
and I had was given a scholarship and
and my father really freaked out and at
that point is is when I was basically
made aware and said Nora you cannot do
that you're also going to be putting
your father in a very awkward position
because I can be basically a black male
and and there is this curse that that
staling had said that he would persecute
up to the third generation and that's
how I ended up in Mexico City and where
I went to school and until I did my
training in in psychiatry
so I would love to expand on this just a
little bit for people who may not
recognize the name Leon Trotsky so
number one we won't go into a huge
Wikipedia page on Leon Trotsky but
people should read the basics and and
find him online very historically
notable very important as you mentioned
as
opposition of sorts with respect to some
very powerful figures in Soviet history
and he also based on my reading please
correct me if I'm wrong but survived
multiple assassination attempts and then
was finally killed but not immediately
by someone with an ice ax that
penetrated his head by something like
seven centimeters
but still managed to subdue with his
guards the attacker and
it he just seems like such a force of
Nature and such a powerful figure to
begin with and so to have that in your
lineage
I would just be so curious to know how
all of that has informed
if if you feel like it has the way you
relate
to the world or even think about history
or voicing your own opinion anything
like that absolutely and there's no way
it doesn't influence you and and be
aware that as a little girl I was living
in that house and and so I was
surrounded by not just the knowledge
that that it was my father's grandfather
and I had basically while until I was
seven eight years old I also his second
wife was living in the house Natalia who
we became a very dear person to me so
when you are born into a house where you
know that you have a relative that did
something that was very motivated
towards improving the the best the next
Generations the chances that next
Generations have that they were
committed to a more just and fair
Society
that is ingrained into your brain and
and both my parents were very systematic
us making us aware that we do have a
responsibility that each one of us as an
individual
you should be recognized that we are
part of of a social system
work out you act as consequences and
that your ass can actually significantly
improve or negatively affect the life of
others
so we all of us the my three sisters and
I have that very much ingrained into our
motivation and how we live our lives and
so for me that has been crucial so I
become very I mean particular and this
is something I've always had
by very sensitive to people the most
vulnerable I mean it just generates this
this drive and and trying to help trying
to make i i a very intolerant of on
injustices I've always been and so it
drives me
crazy it activates my amygdala when I
see someone improperly treated
and obviously as you grow up and you
have different you find yourselves in
positions where you say
what can I do to help and and that has
ultimately led me to take this position
of took me to take the position of
director of the National Institute on
drug abuse
because I realized that it would put me
in a leadership position where I could
influence the knowledge that was derived
in order to affect policies that would
lead to a better opportunity for people
suffering from substance use disorder so
that's that's fundamental to me and that
came from my historical background and
upbringing
what did your father
feel the role or responsibility of
scientists was I'm I'm wondering I
suppose why he said yes
to most things or all things science
related maybe you said yes to most
things for you I have no idea but if if
it happened to be
pretty specific to science why did he do
that why was it important in his mind
I think a lot about it because my father
you know when we were growing up he
could never ever speak about Trotsky and
we were not allowed to ask questions
because it was felt that it was just too
painful for him to speak up and the
first time he did an interview
about his experience with Rosky was when
I was I think I must have been 17 years
of age or 16 years of age
and and that was a turning point for him
where he started to speak about it and I
think my father
an extraordinary individual I mean with
an amazing resilience
was was using certain mechanisms to try
to
deal with the suffering I mean his
mother committed suicide when he was
living with her
I mean he lost his father to a
concentration camp his sister was left
behind in Russia because Stalin did not
allow his mother to take basically only
allowed him to take one of the two
children and so the mother selected the
one that was younger which was my father
and then when he loses the mother he
goes and lives with an uncle and the
uncle is killed by by Stalin while in
Paris and then he ends up with Roski
androsky's assassinator and basically my
father is coming into the house when
mercadar who's the Killer is inside and
he hears him don't let sieva which is
the name of my father
Simi so he has the clarity of mind to
recognize he doesn't want my father to
see him all covered in blood
so if you think about what it must mean
for a child to go this all of these
experiences I think you have to develop
mechanism of protection
and in that respect my view is that
science provides it because science
tends to be very black and white I mean
it's not really black and white I mean
the the physical sciences mathematical
Sciences are black and white biology is
more graded but it do you can extract
objective information that is
reproducible and I think that gives you
a sense of solidity and I think that
this may be one of the reasons why my
father was so attracted to science and
what I can tell you he was very
categorical he did not want any one of
his daughters to go into politics he was
black and white no politics and and his
his perspective was that the family
already had paid a very very big price
because of the of politics and so he
really didn't want to so in that respect
of course science offered these ideal
profession where people were driven by
looking and trying to understand the
truth of things
in objective ways where there was not
that subjective element where things can
creep in and and rapidly be influenced
by one person's perspective now this is
me speculating about why my father was
so driven into the into the science it
may just be that he loved science or
because it's a fantastic field science
is basically you are moving your
curiosity to try on to understand the
world and they pay you for its own so
it's a great a great so so I am making a
speculative leap because I have thought
about it like you sort of asked me but
at the same time I have to recognize
that it may also just be that he loved
science because he's Aquarius very
curious person I'd love to look at other
influences
in your thinking and trajectory and the
name I would like to invoke is Julian
Villarreal and and
I did check the pronunciation before we
started for people wondering and I would
love to know
who this person was and what influence
he had on you if you could describe
Julian was
a pharmacologies that was working in a
pharmaceutical company
and he was a physician and a PhD in
Pharmacology who had gone to
Michigan University for his PhD
and I ended up with him because as a
medical student I knew I wanted to do
research and so I started to volunteer
with one of the
major scientists in Mexico
who was doing work on autopsies and
tissue pathologics he was a pathologist
and he said Nora I do like Behavior do
you like drugs you like the brain let me
introduce you to someone that will
basically have better background than
mine and so he introduced me to Julian
Villarreal and immediately I hit it off
with Julian and what intrigued me so
much about Julian was that he thought
outside the box completely and that
resonated totally with me and he was
interested at that time his research was
on trying to understand what were the
mechanisms that account for the
tolerance to opioids and the mechanisms
that account for the withdrawal that
emerges when someone becomes physically
dependent to opioids and his idea was
that if you have these models and you
could understand them then you would be
able to develop an opioid medication
that would not be addictive that would
not produce tolerance that could not
produce withdrawal
many pharmacologies went into that whole
field and and certainly what I can tell
you as of now no one has succeeded on
getting an opioid medication that is not
addictive and that doesn't produce
tolerance or withdrawal
but but the models that he was using and
the way that he was challenging me which
was very very quantitative he was always
trying to to figure out a way of
quantifying behavior in animals that
then could be used to predict the
responses to drugs
how did Julian
encourage you to think differently well
he was introducing me to a lot of the
analytical methods to be able to Define
variables I mean I realized this was
very much before its time right now for
example a lot of the the analysis that
we do employ vectors as a means to
actually describe a trajectory of
something more than one point and he was
introducing me to those Technologies and
says Nora
learn about it and he would give me
books so that you can try to see how you
apply them to the measures you are
taking on the animal experiments
so
he opened in my brain the whole
curiosity of using quantitative analysis
in ways beyond the traditional very
simplistic statistical methods that we
use
and this is something that now is
fundamental for the type of work that we
are doing in many fields of science but
for me as someone that is in
neurosciences and neuroimaging it is
crucial to basically enable us to
understand and to actually integrate
databases that are very very diverse and
distinct so
Julian I mean he who challenged me he
would basically give me questions that I
that would make me think and I I that's
what I like and I actually he taught me
that and this is something that I as a
mentor now of junk scientists
I basically want I I put them in
positions where I force them to think
and to think differently and I mean for
example one of the the questions I I
always go I mean I you have students and
postdocs and they present me the data
and I ask them well what do you make of
it and they give me an explanation and I
said okay now I want you to give me the
most outrageous explanation that you can
get me of this data in order to force
them to think differently because there
is a predictive element in a lot of the
things that is a reflection of the
influence of others and I want that
Innovative way that Association that
others have not done I want to encourage
them to play with it right because as a
as a mentor especially a mentor
who is highly respected by your mentees
or post-docs or whatever it might be it
would be very easy to
correct them and perhaps in some
respects force your
perspective on them but that doesn't
help them develop the muscle of thinking
differently in the way that you're
describing by asking those types of
probing questions
which makes all the sense in the world
yeah but there's also a selfish
component into it I think that I mean
for me is totally uninteresting to hear
a response that I already would have
thought myself so and I think that
brains work better when you expose them
to unexpected stimuli so I I actually I
think that the scientific creativity is
enriched by having that basically
playing with ideas and Concepts and I
encourage it a lot and so we have Team
meetings where I really probe them for
people to to get into those spaces and
so it's crucial that you Empower them
you make them feel
actually
confident because otherwise people don't
dare they feel intimidated that they may
say some things that others will think
it's stupid and that's so very common
when you are in groups people don't want
to be seen as saying something that that
will make them feel embarrassed and to
me I always actually start meetings and
says look guys we are here to basically
push the limit so please do not feel
embarrassed it's if you don't speak up
we'll never have an opportunity to
understand whether where that idea may
go through so it's something I always
push whether it is with people are my
mentors or I'm organizing it with
experts I I do like to get that going
you have a well-established history I
would say of pushing the limits and
knowing when to push so I would like to
just read something I found
from The Washington Post it's just a few
paragraphs and then I'll ask a question
related to it
here we go in 1984 she that is you left
NYU for an assistant professorship at
the University of Texas Health Science
Center at Houston expecting to continue
her research then they're quoting you
they had a fantastic Imaging Center bulk
offer calls but as it happens quote
there wasn't a single schizophrenic in
the University Hospital end quote what
the hospital did have was cocaine
addicts so you adapted and I'll
summarize a little bit here or just
abbreviate but you said I was probably
the first person to use these new
technologies for the investigation of
drugs of abuse she says but her work was
ignored initially especially her seminal
paper documenting Strokes in the brains
of cocaine abusers
and then this is a quote of you I
started to present these data meetings
and people didn't believe it because
there was no evidence that cocaine was
toxic she says that's fine I said
because this is what the data show she
applied for a grant from Nida
of course everything comes full circle
but she applied for a grant from Nida to
pursue her research and was turned down
it took three years before the British
Journal of Psychiatry finally published
her paper
and then the closing quote from you in
this section is this is what happens
when you come up with things before
their time and my question for you is
what was the experience like and what
was your
inner talk like going through
this sequence of events and having
people dismiss having people reject over
that period of time what was that like
for you and how did you keep going
well I'm a very perseverant person and I
never give up so my perspective is on
this issue has always been like that and
that finding actually I still working on
that to try to understand why how
cocaine affects and producing these
strokes and how we can prevent them and
how we can help people
but at that time I was very young and I
you know you have this sense of you
trust the system and you believe well
maybe I'm not good enough and
we haven't consolidated
that believe in yourself right I mean
because you are you just basically
recently trained you are using no one
had used that technology so
at that point there was this belief that
cocaine was safe so here comes this
person showing this data on images that
others had never seen
and with the background that cocaine was
at that time failed to be safe and I I
submitted it to the New England Journal
of Medicine which is the most important
medical journal clinical medical journal
they review it and they came back again
saying well there's really no evidence
that cocaine can be damaging to the
blood vessels
they were completely wrong and now it's
clear I mean all of that is history no
one will question that cocaine as well
as other stimulant drugs produces
vascular damage and pathology
but it is the way that science goes and
and you sort of say science should be
guided by data but science has a
religious nature to it also and once a
model is created it becomes very
difficult to change it so and it takes a
long long time for Concepts that have
been Consolidated as accepted as the
truth to be questioned and I I see I
mean it happened to me there but I see
it constantly
that statement that I stated there is
very very valid if you come up with
something that it's ahead of its time
you're going to have trouble getting it
accepted and you may not actually
necessarily be recognized for it when it
becomes everyday life then are we
obsessed well what's the big deal that's
in the nature of the scientific progress
but as someone that is directing and
allocating resources for science I am
very sensitive
to ensure
that if there are situations where there
may be something that is very Innovative
that others are not seeing that we don't
curtail it so I tend to in many
instances say okay let's give it the
benefit of the doubt because if it is
correct it's going to be much more
transformative than if we just continue
doing science that follows the rules of
the game very very precisely where
basically what you are expecting you've
already seen so
I do think that we need to push the
limits
with with open access to Scientific
databases this is happening more and
more which is very exciting now
as you mentioned
you have perseverance as a superpower
you it is just a statement of reality
that you don't stop and some people may
not have that constitutionally when you
are mentoring or having conversations
with say younger scientists who are
facing their first pushback they're
getting rejected they're having to try
again and again maybe they're feeling
demoralized what do you say to them
I say you know this happened to me I
mean my first grant was basically just
Red Line totally and absolutely
and I was very depressed and
at that time actually people in The
Institute that naida said Nora
try again and and I was in that respect
and again I I do not take no for an
answer and this is a message that I say
to young people you should dare to do
things
and no one has the right to say you
cannot bring A New Perspective into
things
and so I always say be daring and
persevere I mean with all of my postdoc
students
they get rejected on a paper they get
rejected on a grant I mean the answer is
just
stand up and jump back on the horse I
mean it's just like as simple as that
and for those who who aren't watching
any video
you are very tough you're very
physically fit you're very mentally fit
and you walk the walk so I want to just
give people
further evidence that you very much walk
that walk and I'm gonna segue now to
perhaps a discussion of the difference
between studying compounds and
experiencing compounds and I was hoping
you could tell the story of how you
became acquainted with Demerol
it's interesting you know because I love
Demerol I probably shouldn't be saying
these things but what happened to me I
was in a horrible car accident I was the
passenger and there was one of those
hits that the car it was I see the car
that was a 90 degree
flip and the car in the opposite
direction comes in and Strikes me in the
passenger seat
seeing the car coming to me I did not
want my brain to be hit by a car and and
so I said okay I put my food into the
car to protect my hair and to get my
hair as far away as I could from the
door because I saw it coming
and so I did not get hit in the head
fortunately but the door was came
crashing and I was trapped my leg was
dropping was broken I was under a lot of
pain and I wanted to lose Consciousness
because the pain was so intense and so
they finally they had to come up with
this jaws of life to open up the door
because they couldn't get me they get me
into the ambulance take me to the
hospital
and there the doctor says Nora we have
to try to move the fracture so that we
can accelerate the healing so otherwise
we're going to have to go for surgery so
we're going to give you Demerol and they
injected me with them and only it was
extraordinary not just that the
intensity of the suffering was
disappearing everything was fascinating
and opioids make you sleepy and I was
forcing myself not to sleep because
everything was so extraordinary
and so it gave me an Insight of how
powerful that drug was that despite
everything that was there I wanted to be
aware of every sensation
and they admitted me to the hospital and
I had to spend two nights and three days
and I recall I was in terrible pain and
they would give me the Demerol and it
was this sense of well-being
extraordinary sense of well-being from
the opioid
and that is the only time that I've had
a real ability to have a consciousness
of how an opioid makes you feel
and so when they discharged me they
discharged me on Monday the accident was
on Friday
I was waiting on the car and I felt all
chemical everything felt very unreal and
the doctor had sent me home with two
weeks of medication for the pain and I
stopped I stopped cold turkey low and be
called I did have withdrawal over the
night and it was so bad I didn't
understand that first what was happening
I was Restless it was worse than pain
and sometimes you need to experience
these things to understand that you say
what can be worse than pain it was just
I could not be comfortable no matter
what so I took one of the pills that he
had given me and that was the last I
took and then the the physical
dependence that was responsible for that
withdrawal disappear
and that's it that's my story with
opioids which made me very aware that I
do not want to be exposed to obvious
unless I have horrible pain because I
can see their Allure I can see how
someone could easily fall into that
Nirvana that chemical Nirvana that they
create
and that's the story of that Demerol and
that's why I say I did I have to be
honest it was an extraordinary
experience for me to have been able to
feel what it was but it was also a very
scary one
super scary I had nothing nearly that
severe but I had a terrible shoulder
injury that ended up requiring
reconstruction but in the emergency room
when I ended up in the hospital they
were overbooked under staffed they had
gunshot victims and so on who took
precedence of course and so I was
sitting there with my arm dislocated
sort of sticking out of my chest for
hours and they gave me morphine and I
remember thinking two things the first
was this is incredible the number two
was I should never ever touch anything
like this again and so after my surgery
when they sent me home and they gave me
Vicodin and this that and the other
thing they gave me a whole collection of
different painkillers and fortunately
some of them I took for just a few days
and they made me nauseous and I was very
happy that they made me nauseous because
it made me less likely to use them yeah
but I do have I suppose a first-hand
acquired fear and then a developed fear
just from the experience of people in my
family and my and my friends what is the
current state how should people think
about the current state of addiction and
overdose crises in the U.S
well it's unfortunate I wish it were
different but it is in a state of very
severe over those deaths that are very
difficult to control and regulate and
what we are observing is that we are
seeing
more and more people die with very
diverse demographics from overdoses
which again makes it so very hard to
control because at the beginning the
crisis started because we started to
over prescribe opioid medications and
people diverted them and people also who
should have not been given them because
they didn't have severe pain syndromes
became addicted and that opened up the
door for heroin and then we started to
see a rise in 2011 more or less of
heroin injection heroin and people dying
and then in 2016 there was a
transformative very malignant change
which was the introduction of Fentanyl
and Centennial we all been hearing about
it in the news is a synthetic opioid
that was developed in order to have a
more potent analgesic is widely utilized
in medicine for breakthrough pain for
cancer patients just for example when
the medications that they have no longer
controls the pain you can use fentanyl
but it's also widely used by
anesthesiologist because when you
combine fentanyl with an anesthetic you
you actually can control and regulate
much better the level of consciousness
of your patients so it's a very useful
drug
but it is by its potency
it is highly highly addictive
it's also highly dangerous because of
its potency it can make you stop
breathing very very rapidly and it's a
drug that is very cheap to manufacture
you don't need to cultivate any plant
you synthesize it and in the synthesis
is very simple and because it's so
potent you need 50 times less volume
of drugs so you can bring it through the
borders much more easily than with
heroin or any other drug that we know of
and so it has both pharmacological
effects that make it dangerous but also
the production makes it actually very
enticing for the drug dealers so they
are incentivized to distribute it and
that's what we've seen accelerated
during the covet pandemic basically
fentanyl permeated all of the country
everywhere and so they started to also
mix it with other drugs like cocaine or
Methamphetamine and now more recently
with
counterfeit pills that are so like
Adderall which is an amphetamine or like
Ativan which is a benzodiazepine that
you use for anxiety or sleep or even
these guys as Vicodin which is an opioid
medication for pain they sell them on
the web and they are less expensive than
the real thing so people it's not just
that people that are addicted to opioids
can overdose now those that are taking
cocaine can overdose those that can take
methamphetamine can overdose and
students that may buy appeal in order to
study for an exam May overdose and die
because the pill they got had fentanyl
or a person cannot get their Physicians
to prescribe them as sleep medicine they
go and buy it on the web and they
overdose so this is the nature of the
major challenges that we have
and we're seeing more and more new
substances emerging which is like again
running in a treadmill because we
develop antidotes for the overdoses from
fentanyl but now they are mixing
fentanyl with anesthetic that is used in
veterinary medicine silasin and that
actually silasin does not respond to
Narcan which is the antidote that we use
for fentanyl so this Shifty nature of
the drugs that people are exposed to the
fact that they are increasingly more
potent and the fact that they are
basically disguised in many ways is
expanding the number of people that are
now overdosing and in some instances we
don't have good strategies that we can
use to help them to revert those
overdoses
yeah it's it's such a complex evolving
ecosystem of compounds and as you
mentioned there are so many incidental
or accidental ways to ingest for example
Fentanyl and I know of many direct
stories where people have gone to a
bachelor party they try a little bit of
some drug that ends up being cut with
fentanyl I know of two people
specifically one just dropped dead on
the floor one fell into a coma from what
would have been considered low doses of
illicit drugs but they happen to be cut
with fentanyl which is horrifying and in
fact my friend who died was not himself
an addict he was collateral damage one
of my other friends I grew up with there
are a lot of drug issues where I grew up
was a heroin addict he had developed in
just an incredible tolerance to Fentanyl
and he gave it to my other friend to
help with his hangover and my other
friend had never used any opiates and he
fell asleep and just never woke up so
the the sheer
ease with which
the fentanyl as you mentioned sort of
permeates different corners and
neighborhoods of society and which does
not discriminate in terms of or I
shouldn't say it doesn't discriminate
but it has infiltrated every
socioeconomic class it's really
pervasive and and really terrifying what
is your perspective on the war on drugs
and perhaps any other
approaches that you think may be more
effective
and I'll answer it but I guess actually
that story that you just told of your
friend that how he beg taking fentanyl
on by knowing what it was it just killed
him and this is what we are observing a
lot and I think it's important to
educate people that this is a seriously
dangerous drugs and I I unfortunately I
think that we have cried wolf so many
many times that we've lost credibility
but if there was a way that we could
convey that in very objective we don't
need to exaggerate in any way I mean
fentanyl it's two milligrams will kill
you and the counterfeit Pills contain
five milligrams some of them two doses
to kill you so it is very very tragic
coming back to your question in terms of
the war on drugs and they were on drugs
I think that
basically what it did was it created a
mechanism that could perpetuate
structural racism it is very tragic to
see how its enforcement led to the
incarceration of young black Americans
and again that system that punitive
system where someone could be stopped
and this will happen if you are black
and
on the notion that you had drugs with
you and thrown in jail or prison because
you had
drugs on you is such an unfair system
and it didn't work in any way because it
did not reduce the amount of drugs that
people were taking or the negative
consequences draw to drugs to our
society
so it did not work and I think one of
the aspects that it did show is if you
do throw a person that's taking drugs in
jail
if you criminalize that person that's
using drugs like for example we did it
horribly with with crack cocaine so if
you were smoking crack cocaine he was
like
I don't recall exactly but it was at
least 10 times greater penalty that if
you were just snorting cocaine it's not
in cocaine or injecting cocaine
hydrochloride was much more favored by
white people whereas crack was favored
by black people so
cocaine hydrochloride white crack
cocaine black why do you see such a
difference in it is the same cocaine
basically it's cocaine is cocaine and
yet one called noted a much higher
penalty than the other that's an example
of the consequences but what science has
shown is that when you do throw people
into jail or prisons that have a problem
with substance use disorders
then when they leave they are at much
greater risk of first of all relapsing
immediately into the Rock taking and
escalating their drug taking so you are
exacerbating the nature of the problem
by putting them in jail and prison so it
doesn't work no matter what you do and
that's why the the whole notion of
criminalizing
the person that takes drugs is basically
very negative vis-a-vis the outcomes of
the person and also in no way is the
benefits Society it is actually very
costly by itself when an issue becomes
politicized it becomes much harder to
change and shift
and we've seen I mean I think that we've
seen over the past I would say
certainly five or eight years
an openness to recognizing that they
were on drugs did not work and that
criminalizing drug users is basically a
negative and is promoting structural
racism
so I'd like to
cover quite a few things
I would like to get to harm reduction
I'd like to do that a little bit later
and to hear your perspectives on that
first I wanted to
go from the problems that you've
described to looking at pushing the
limits daring to do things some of the
perhaps
novel or developing potential approaches
to treating addiction and there are
several things I'd like to talk about
certainly you have recently I want to
say written about TMS and deep brain
stimulation I would like to talk about
those first I thought we might
speak about psychedelics and psychedelic
assisted therapy and I wanted to
congratulate and thank you for being one
of the first if not the first Institute
director to fund psychedelic research
with humans after the scientific winter
following the Nixon Administration which
interestingly enough at least I've read
that some of the controlled substance
act and Nixon's decisions around that
were motivated by controlling certain
demographics or having the
pretense of being able to search and
seize and so on
that was from I think it was erlichmann
in his that might not have been cabinet
but sort of inner circle but coming back
to the treatment side of things
could you speak to
perhaps what we know already about
psychedelics as treatments what is
interesting and what Milestones I think
this is a question on a lot of minds and
you're very qualified to speak to this
what Milestones still need to be reached
to instill confidence in these drugs as
Therapeutics I think it's a very
interesting potentially promising area
of
Therapeutics
the way that I see it is the evidence
that exists is is very limited but is
sufficiently intriguing that you cannot
ignore it and behooves you in in terms
of
why we are
identifying this as a priority area of
research in the whole issue of
psychotherapeutics of the use of
psychedelic drugs
the data is strongest for the use of
Silo saving for depression toys have
shown and I think that even though the
sample sizes are not very large they
have consistently shown improve the
outcomes on patients with terminal
illnesses
most of them I think if I recall
correctly were with cancer in whom the
psilocybin allowed them to accept better
emotionally the fact that this was a
terminal illness and improved their
depression scores
and that was quite significant there's
also data showing
potential for
PTSD the use of psychedelic drugs so
this may be the two disease conditions
for which there's more data
the clinical trials are limited in
Sample sizes and in numbers but the
effect size says
are significant despite the small sample
sizes there are some studies that have
been done in substance use disorder
nicotine is one of them
alcohol use disorders alcoholism is
another one and again both of them are
on psilocybing and for both of them
there is also this positive effect
and what's intriguing and speaking about
it in terms of the nicotine is that the
effects actually appear to be larger
than the ones that you see with the
medications that we use for the
treatment of nicotine dependence
just like Chantix or nicotine
replacement Therapies
so the number of people that stop
smoking is actually significantly
greater than that that is the percentage
that stops smoking with medications that
have been approved by the FDA but it's a
story number one only one study and the
sample sizes are small so that's why
we're funding the researchers this is a
group at John Hopkins University
to actually replicate that story so the
data is quite interesting but it is very
preliminary and I do want to emphasize
this because sort of people like to make
conclusions before
the evidence is out there and my concern
is that and you already see it you go
into the web and there's a lot of sites
advertising
treatments with psychedelic drugs not
just for mental illnesses but for also
for well-being when the data is not
there and so we don't know first of all
if we need to replicate why but assume
that you replicate and it does work what
are the doses how to give it what are
potential negative side effects I mean
what clinical trials have reported is in
a small number of people there is a risk
of suicidal behaviors and suicidality so
who is at risk to show that how do you
actually if you start to see it how can
you prevent it how do should you
administer the psychedelic drug
it is been believed that the psychedelic
drug is adjunctive therapy that it is
the interaction with the therapist while
you're under the influence of the
psychedelic drug that it is therapeutic
that's one of the hypothesis so how you
should be administering how do
psychotherapists gets involved and all
of these are scientific questions that
we need to basically explore with
research because we don't have the data
there that is needed to build up and if
we don't build up and people start to
use it and they start to have negative
effects like suicides then that can lead
to actually the geopardizing the future
use of these medications the FDA may say
this is too dangerous or the DEA may say
this is too dangerous we are not going
to agree to its utilization
and that is where the danger comes
around of of pushing something to
preliminary
I agree that certainly the positioning
of of psychedelics is Panacea which we
see a lot is
really putting the cart before the horse
in a lot of ways and there are risks
which is why there are exclusionary
criteria at places like Johns Hopkins
for certain conditions whether it's
schizophrenia or bipolar disorder or
others and I'd love to chat a little bit
about
study design and what researchers might
do or consider to make their studies and
Grant applications more
appealing to
institutes like Nida and the reason that
I'd love to explore that a bit is many
smart scientists are now paying
attention to this including younger
scientists who are considering this as a
career Focus
and as it stands right now there's a
very small pool of serious
independent philanthropists or
foundations who are providing funding
it's very small I would say
it may be in the 15 to 20 person range
really when we're looking at anyone
donating above a hundred thousand
dollars a year it's very small
and
then on the other hand you have and I
think there's a role certainly an
important role for
market-based for-profit Solutions and
providers but you have sponsored
research on the other end of the
spectrum and night has been very
forward-looking in the sense that you've
provided funding to
Dr Matt Johnson and
and so on at Hopkins looking at nicotine
addiction I would love to know and I'll
just provide a little bit more
thought I know this is going to be a
very long question and then to get your
thoughts on what people might do to make
their applications or studies more
appealing one of the challenges is
certainly that is is brought up
oftentimes is blinding and these studies
or these compounds and the experiences
Associated are really highly
discriminable in the sense that most
people know they are either in the
control group or not and you have
potential active placebos and people
have experimented with niacin some
people have considered higher doses of
say cannabinoids but it's difficult it
seems to find look-alike drugs that do
not
also bring similar actions or effects
do you think there's a place for say
comparative efficacy studies where you
might have
by analogy Psychotherapy versus X right
the people who are getting Psychotherapy
are going to be aware they're getting
psychotherapy but you could compare it
with another therapy where you could
compare psilocybin force a nicotine
addiction to nicotine replacement
therapy
those are just a couple of
I suppose a bit of connective tissue for
people who may not have more context but
what would you like scientists to pay
attention to what would you implore them
to try to do with their studies and
Designs if they want to try to get more
Federal funding
well I think that I mean certainly
you've discussed and and there's no
Simple Solutions I mean of how difficult
it is to control for a placebo but it is
an important one so one of the the
recommendations is to use a very low
dose of the psychedelic drug so you are
giving them the psychedelic drug but uh
at those that is considered to be super
therapeutic and that's what some of the
researchers are doing right now and to
follow all of the guidelines and
practices when you are doing you're
going to be doing a randomized clinical
trial which are the ones that you
basically divide participants some get
the active intervention others do not
and you randomize it and you follow them
and
that's the way that you actually collect
data that then allows you to determine
if there is a difference or not
but I think that
the grantees that are coming up with
proposals
no these I mean how to propose one of
the randomized clinical trials one of
the things that we work with grantees to
which is important is that we help them
in terms of the interactions with the
FDA because the FDA at the end of the
day is the one that's going to be able
to say what data do they need in order
to be able to consider that a clinical
trial is done in a way that they make it
feel comfortable to approve an
indication for a psychedelic drug or not
so it is crucial that they work with the
from the beginning as they are planning
to do their clinical trial that they
engage with the FDA and we absolutely
help them I mean we try to to provide
them support in if the FDA for example
wants them to do toxicology X or
toxicology why or look at the
biodistribution there are certain things
that we can through our contracts help
them obtain
and we are specifically requesting this
and I'm speaking right now of clinical
trials if grantees there may be other
other scientific questions that are very
valid that are not just a randomized
clinical trial that we also would be
very interested on the
on funding for example with brain
Imaging you can now look at how and
there was a paper there's one paper that
actually look at the effects of
psilocybin I think it was psilocybin
either LSD or psilocybin I don't recall
and you're looking at we have these
brain networks that interact with one
another and what they showed was that
that architecture of network was
significantly disrupted during the
hallucination state when the drug was on
board and so if you can do research that
can identify biomarkers of the effects
of the psychedelic drug that's that's
one area that were interesting but also
through those studies can you understand
the mechanisms that are responsible for
the therapeutic benefits so by looking
at how the brain changes its operations
and then you can determine if that is
associated with therapeutic benefit you
can start to understand mechanisms of
actions of psychedelic drugs
we're also funding researchers to
develop we know what the Psychedelic
drugs that we currently have but with
chemistry you can create other
psychedelic drugs for example that may
have the same pharmacological Target but
they don't produce hallucinatory
experiences that which would make it
much easier to actually Implement so we
are interested in a whole gamut of
research
that could help Advance our
understanding of the potential of
psychedelic drugs for Therapeutics
the entire category of sort of non
hallucinatory psychedelic compounds is
very interesting I think there's there
appears to be there appear to be some
very interesting indications that might
be really favorable targets for these
what are sometimes called the
cycloplastogens like cluster headaches
in the case of LSD or LSD analogs
what would you make and then the answer
could be that they're mistaken of
researchers who report based on all the
documentation from subjects in these
various studies whether at UCSF and I
think the the Imaging that you were
mentioning maybe Robin Carhartt Harris
and and his team because they do a lot
of functional MRI and imaging looking at
the perhaps increased entropy or
connectivity or both
communication wise in the brain on these
experiences anyway in that case it would
be
psilocybin or silos 7 and
what would you make potentially of the
importance of meaning making and that is
to say
beyond the activity signature that you
can track or the receptor Affinity the
the reports from subjects that it's the
meaning making in these sessions which
seem to be in part
hand in hand with the hallucinations the
Psychedelic experience relating to how
they see themselves and the world that
lead to the behavioral change and the
durability of some of these effects
rather than
you know dendritic spine growth or any
number of of changes that you can
observe
but given that the duration of some of
these sessions is four to six hours
let's just say and
the half-life is pretty short but some
of the effects seem to be quite durable
with say the
existential distress and terminal cancer
patients and also for nicotine
is there a way to include those factors
as an area of inquiry in addition to the
sort of mechanistic studies and the
basic science and the Imaging of course
and there's been actually papers that
have done that that actually have looked
at the association between the intensity
of the subjective experience and their
therapeutic benefits and then have shown
that those that have the more intense
mystical experience had the better
therapeutic response but that that
element of meaning and understanding is
basically not in any way it's
exclusionary with that of
neuroplasticity
because it may be that in fact that that
experience that you have there while you
are leaving it under the effect of the
hallucinogenic drug May generate a
longer lasting manner memory because of
those neuroplastic effects and again
highlighting why
that combination of the drug itself with
the psychotherapeutic intervention
becomes crucial so you cannot certainly
separate them I mean to me if it can be
corroborating that there is this
neuroplasticity and we learn to use it
properly then imagine how extraordinary
it is to be able to generate a window in
time whereby exposing you to a stimuli
under the effect of the psychedelic drug
if it in fact turns to be the case you
could strengthen a particular memory and
that would allow you to actually cover a
memory that may be very painful so you
are competing one memory against the
other
so I think that this is to me one of the
most fascinating areas about why I think
that these psychedelic drugs deserve
attention for research yeah because to
have a means to monitor to accelerate
learning and memory process these
neuroplasticity long-term potentiation
phenomena that we've been studying in
Neuroscience could be a very powerful
tool yeah it's been very exciting to be
involved with some of the early stage
science and to see it develop over time
and also have a lot of misgivings about
the
public discussion when it veers into the
land of Panacea because these things are
absolutely not Panacea and they're very
I believe powerful compounds based on
the data that we have so far one more
question maybe maybe two more questions
about this and then I would love to move
to TMS which I am increasingly
fascinated by I was a a subject in a
study involving TMS long time ago but
the the technology was pretty primitive
then my question is about substance use
disorders and
the very preliminary but very
preliminary hypothesis that psychedelics
and specifically psilocybin so the same
molecule
appears to have effects across
drugs of abuse meaning or potential
abuse so if you have let's say the work
of Michael Bogan shoots and others at
NYU looking at alcohol use disorder
psilocybin then you have
Matt Johnson Dr Matt Johnson and
nicotine you also have people like Peter
Hendricks looking at cocaine
if it turns out that those can be
replicated we can hopefully and I'm very
optimistic that there'll be more Federal
funding for these things because there
is a bit of a chicken in the egg problem
in terms of sample size and funding
availability which is challenging but
what could it mean if it turns out that
something like psilocybin is effective
across multiple compounds is that is
that common I simply don't know in other
sort of Frontline treatments
or would that be something novel that
would raise very interesting questions
in your mind about the nature of
addiction
I've installed in as a researcher
multiple addictions I mean cocaine
alcohol
methamphetamine nicotine and more
recently opioids and heroin also and
I've been intrigued about what do all of
these addictions have in common in fact
I've been intrigued about how what
something like morbid obesity has in
common with addiction if you look at the
brain because they all share as a common
phenomenological presentation the
compulsiveness of the behavior the and
the loss of self-regulation so you
cannot stop it and you just basically
escalate on that behavior so I've been
intrigued about recognizing the common
elements in the brain and then of course
studying also their uniqueness but they
are the neural circuitry is basically
very similar what is different is the
way that you engage it so to me it's in
and of itself is not surprising that
that you have a therapeutic that is
going to be valuable for multiple
addictions and we're funding other type
of research with other molecules with
the aim of basically targeting just a
medication for addiction in general
so that we could also start to address
the problem of poly substance addictions
that we have right without having to
just go specific so it doesn't per se
surprise me what I would be very
intrigued in that notion is if we were
to understand the mechanism and a common
mechanism across all of the addictions
is that you create long-term
potentiation
in reward circuits so you are
strengthening the signaling on systems
that basically are associating the drug
with pleasure and reward and you are
weakening the signaling that's
associating pleasure and reinforcement
for other stimuli and rewards so just
just actually a strengthening processes
and Awakening processing and you
generate it in such a a way that you've
created an artificial
need for that drug just like to have a
need for food now you have an artificial
need for the drug and I'm very much
intrigued about the similarities with
pain when you have pain where the insult
is no longer there but the memory of
that pain continues making you feel it
right just like in the addicted person
the memory of the pleasure leads you to
continue wanting it so it's not just
that I think it could be beneficial for
different types of drugs but I do think
there's value in actually even
considering the extent to which if there
are shown to be able to modify
neuroplasticity treatments for these
chronic pain conditions which are
devastating and for which you really
don't have anything I mean not that I
know that there's much research into it
but I'm just telling you where my brain
is jumping into yeah absolutely so a few
things come to mind if you haven't
looked at the work of Google Dolan
g-u-l-d-o-l-e and she's at Hopkins
her perspective is is quite different
from say Robin Carhart Harris and I I
think she has some very interesting
hypotheses around these windows of
reopening of critical windows with
respect to say plasticity and then on
the chronic pain topic I will say this
was done at a above board very well
run Clinic with proper medical
supervision but I went through two weeks
of
ketamine infusion several years ago not
because I was depressed but because I
wanted to be able to speak firsthand to
the experience because I knew I would
have a lot of questions about it
from friends and also audience and so on
I'm not a doctor I don't play one on the
internet just to be very clear but what
was fascinating to me is I went in
having read a lot of the research
related to depression and I've since had
Dr John Crystal from Yale on the show to
to have a very long conversation about
all things ketamine what I didn't
realize though when I went in because I
was not going in with with any severe
depression
is or I couldn't have anticipated what
happened and that was for me I had
chronic back pain in my in my mid
thoracic back from a long-standing
injury which was very severe
had daily pain intense pain for
10 years let's call it and when I left
my two weeks of infusions I had no back
pain for about six months and it turns
out one of the other primary indications
is chronic pain so there's a lot to
recommend psilocybin over ketamine
at psychedelic dosing but
it matches very well with what you were
saying about the potential overlap of
plasticity and not just for indications
like depression but also for something
like chronic pain
yeah no but and I wasn't thinking of
ketamine because I wasn't thinking I
mean ketamini is not considered as you
know a classical psychedelic drug right
but there is a lot of work on Research
ongoing for the value of ketamine for
the treatment of chronic pain what I
would like to sort of look and I look at
it in terms of what has been done
because again this is all of these areas
are under investigated but I'm going to
check it out because I want to be to see
if anyone has published anything on
psilocybin for chronic pain so I was
jumping into the classical psychedelics
which have very different mechanism of
actions than ketamine but absolutely I
mean and I think ketamine was the drug
that let us open up the the doors to say
here we have a drug that nobody that is
a dissociative type of drug
that is also a drug that has that can
produce addiction as psychedelic
classical psychedelic Stone and yet
despite everybody's prejudices show to
be beneficial for treatment of
depression yeah so I think that that is
an example about why we cannot just
close our eyes and says no and we need
to look at this classical psychedelics
so I would like you made me now curious
about it but I suspect so also the fact
as you were mentioning earlier that
there may be is room for potentially
stripping out some of the Psychedelic
effects I think we need to keep in mind
that the business motivations may not
always be aligned with clinical outcomes
of course it would be much more
convenient to work with these compounds
if they didn't elicit the types of
hallucinations we've discussed but even
something that is non-classical
psychedelic let's say salvan RNA right
so you have a opioid Agonist
may have some really interesting
applications for minimizing damage after
stroke
that you know for for vascular problems
super super fascinating of course more
research is needed
so I wanted to
shift to TMS and deep brain stimulation
and this is very interesting to me we
were talking about sort of different
activity or maybe pathological activity
in different neuroanatomical structures
I don't know if the nucleus accumbens
fits into both that prior discussion and
the TMS and deep brain stimulation but
could you speak to what TMS is what deep
brain stimulation is and why they are of
Interest
oh they are incredible interest and I'm
going to introduce you to a new
technology that has my brain even more
excited than TMS okay
TMS goes for transcranial magnetic
stimulation and is a technology that is
not invasive you actually administer
magnetic currents in the scalp and then
these magnetic currents actually go into
the cortex of the brain and they are
signal transferred as electrical signals
and it can be used to modulate either at
high frequencies to stimulate or it's
sort of lower frequencies to inhibit the
areas that you are targeting and by
understanding how in the cortex because
the cortex I mean the brain is a very
complicated Network and so it links with
almost everything else but they are
hopes they are areas that act as cops
that is they have many more connections
some of them go deep into the brain so
as you understand better that pattern of
connectivity you can deliver TMs in such
a way that you can start to reach areas
that are deeper in the brain which are
very important for diseases of
depression and this is of of a certainly
addiction I mean you were speaking about
the nucleus accumbens which is the main
required region of the brain and all of
the drugs of abuse all of them stimulate
it and when you stimulate that in
animals with electrical currents or with
optogenetics to generate regarding
signals the transcranial magnetic
stimulation cannot reach deep but you
can reach it indirectly and that's what
they use it and it's a technology that's
approved for the treatment of depression
different stimulation then basically is
an invasive procedure you put the
electrodes inside the brain and the
treatment of it's being used for example
for treatment of addiction research is
being used for research also treatment
of depression and other diseases
and the nuclear circumvents is one of
the main targets both for depression as
well as for addiction
but there are other neuromodulation
Technologies so transcranial magnetic
the other one is direct electrical
current stimulation which instead of
giving magnetic signals from the outside
to give the electrical pulses but the
one that I am very intrigued and I want
to actually introduce you to it if you
haven't heard about it is low low
intensity ultrasound so it uses
ultrasound and if you can use it with
high intensity or low intensity and you
apply it on the outside of the brain if
you use high intensity you can very
specifically create an ablation so you
can do what you could do with surgery
but very precisely without having to
open the hair but that's high intensity
the beauty of the low intensities you do
not produce damage to the tissue but you
can modify it for a long time so they
are doing research right now and they
high intensity ultrasound was recently
approved for Parkinson's Disease and
they are high intensity the high
intensity but the researchers are
looking at low intensity for
neurological diseases and for addiction
and other mental illness and the beauty
is that sound
goes through the tissue so you can
Target your nucleus accumbens directly
with a much greater Precision that with
transcranial magnetic stimulation okay
yeah that's super interesting it's
fascinating and you need to apply it for
10 minutes and the pile of data is
showing that you see it for say the
effects are two weeks or four weeks with
a single stimulation with a single
session of 10 minutes yes wow okay
that's very interesting it's final data
right that's what I say now that you're
speaking to me and last time we spoke I
was I'm very excited of TMS I'm not in
any way going to minimize it but
actually what I like so much and I'm
just going to say well you push the
limit and I said let's push our own
thinking if you are able to do these
long lasting effect through this as you
learn to understand better how these
frequencies for ultrasound stimulation
affect the tissue I think that one day
we may be able to cure addiction and no
one has ever heard me speak about cure
addiction yeah so why do I think it is
possible because we know that when
people have strokes in certain areas of
the brain particularly frequently
involving the insula
there are cases where people just stop
taking the drug
they forget about taking the drug they
don't care anymore about it so there's
been instances which have shown that the
insult
a stroke in a particular area cure the
person of their addiction so what about
if we gain that knowledge about what are
the relevant circuits and areas and we
have the tools now to manipulate them in
ways that are much more effective than
we had in the past data opens up the
possibility of in the future that we may
be able to cure addiction well that
makes me feel much more optimistic and
I also feel like at some point and I'm
getting ahead of myself but looking at
these
novel
Cutting Edge Technologies or in some
cases very old Technologies like
psilocybin being applied to conditions
in novel ways that at some point there
might be poly therapies that combine
some of these factors let me ask you a
question about the Parkinson's for a
second though because I have Parkinson's
on one I think now both sides of my
family so it's of intense interest if
they're using high frequency and for
those who don't know the term ablation
and I want you to please correct me if
I'm wrong but that can be surgical
removal of tissue or I suppose
destruction of tissue might be another
way to put it
I want you to correct my definition if
I'm getting it wrong but how would that
strength of effect be used in
Parkinson's
it is the high intensity ultrasound and
the high intensity ultrasounds becomes
ablative so you are targeting for
example the subtalamic nuclei just like
you do with surgery but in this case you
are not opening it up and you can very
precisely damage it yeah so this brings
psychosurgery to a completely new level
wow and so they applied it and they're
also I think that one of the targets is
a subtleamic nuclei but I also think
that they've they targeted parts of a
very small nuclear in the thalamus too
so it is fascinating also from that
perspective of in instances where
psychosurgery may be valuable that you
can do it as minimally invasive and as
precisely and as smaller area as
possible so I think is
is quite remarkable now you got me all
excited about this low intensity
ultrasound
I've been following the TMS pretty
closely and in particular the shorter
duration higher frequency
dosing of TMS so let's just say multiple
sessions a day over the span of five
days there's some interesting work being
done
and certainly I know the plural of
anecdote does not equal data but
anecdotally I've seen a number of
outcomes with friends children who are
patients that have practically Justified
belief but on the low intensity
ultrasound side you mentioned and we'll
put links in the show notes for people
and maybe I'll get some links from you
or your team just where people can learn
more about this I know it's pilot data
so gonna hold your horses the jury is
still out but nonetheless very
interesting
place to begin is the
in addition to the durability that
you're mentioning which I think was two
to four weeks let's just say after a
single 10 minute session is the onset of
effect
immediate or near immediate
as well it's basically almost immediate
wow and one of the consistent findings
that they are seeing is that their CR
reduction in anxiety they see a
reduction in craving yeah and it's pilot
work I want to reiterate that it needs
to be replicated but you know when I saw
that pilot date I said oh my God and it
was the group that was Virginia who has
been doing the cycle basically the deep
brain stimulation for the treatment of
opioid addiction and they insert these
electrodes and then they've basically
observed that in three of the four
individuals that they've treated on that
pilot study they basically they were
able to again very dramatically reduce
anxiety and they decrease the the
consumption of opioids so it showed a
positive effect in three or four and
they I mean they basically told me these
effects that we're getting with a low
low intensity ultrasound that they've
tested eight people are as dramatic or
more dramatic the one we're seeing with
with basically the deep brain
stimulation of the nucleus accumbens so
they target also the nucleus accompense
with with low intensity ultrasound so
it's very intriguing I'm a scientist and
I love and I get excited with data but I
do want to reiterate it's very pilot
it's very very pilot but it has to
install it it's liquid yeah what we were
saying with a psychedelic drugs it's
very interesting it has to be study yeah
everything starts small almost
everything starts small right we all
start with the pilots so the jury is
still out but it's exciting that
you're pushing the limits and
they're daring to push the envelope and
experiment with new things of course I
mean that's that's part of the charter
but you also have a history of doing
this well and I don't think you would
have arrived where you are today had you
not been very dogged and determined yeah
it just goes goes all the way back to
when you were you were turned down by
Nida and here you are as the Director
it's just remarkable it's just a
remarkable story so Dr volkoff
you've been very generous with your time
I've enjoyed the conversation I could
keep going for another two hours no
problem but you have an incredibly busy
schedule is there anything else that you
would like to share with people out
there any requests to my audience
anything at all that you would like to
say before we wind to a close there are
two things
addiction is very frequently comorbid
with other psychiatric disorders and and
most notable is anxiety depression
suicidality and I bring it up because
you need to address these
come more with conditions because
otherwise it's not going to be possible
for the person to be able to recover and
also from the perspective that if you
are depressed if you are anxious if you
are suicidal you are likely to take
drugs as a mean to Auto Medicaid to
escape that mental state and it is
crucial to send these this message
because it actually is not as simple as
saying that you take drugs because you
want to get high and and you're taking
the drugs I mean people are taking the
drugs too many times initially yes for
curiosity or many times to feel good but
but once you become addicted it is
really to escape a mental state that
that is very difficult to stay at it's
very in a way very painful
and the other point that I did want to
bring to that we haven't discussed which
is in understanding how we understand
the effects of drugs and addiction and
how we understand also mental illness is
how important the environmental factors
are and how crucial they are
particularly where when you are a child
or another lesson and that I think that
we've all become much more sensitized to
them with a covet pandemic because we
came to realize that there are certain
people that we're at moderator
disadvantage and that's those that deal
with people that are in circumstances of
economic inequality of trauma during
childhood and what we call the Social
determinants of Health that are really
playing very important roles in people's
encounter with drugs and how they
respond to it and how they ultimately
Also may be given an opportunity or not
to access treatment and and to how they
respond to treatment so as you were
speaking for example with psychedelic
drugs we are very concerned that if a
psychedelic therapist if they basically
get into Mainstay clinical practice if
they are proven to be useful that they
are Equitable and it doesn't end up like
many of the very fancy treatments that
we have now that are only accessible to
a very few so that's the only other
thing that I would want to say
I 100 agreed on both and that's that's
also part of the reason that I hope we
will see whether it's with psychedelic
therapies psychedelic assisted therapies
or other modalities
in some cases options for group
treatment and at least the testing of
the hypothesis that outcomes can not
only be
equal to individual treatment but
potentially even in even better and I I
think there is the possibility that that
is the case which would also have the
wonderful side effect of decreasing
costs quite significantly and there's so
many questions of insurance
reimbursement and
ultimately
you know reclassification
which which would be sort of a precursor
to a lot of these things happening but I
agree with you absolutely completely and
it's also as upsetting and
pessimistic is one can become when they
look at the compounding of many of the
addiction problems in the U.S
I feel like we are at a
at a point in history also with some of
these burgeoning Technologies
as you mentioned and I think it was
obvious in the excitement in your voice
I mean there are things potentially on
the horizon that could really change how
we not only treat addiction but how we
think about addiction as well which is
very exciting and I think cause for a
certain degree of
of cautious optimism oh yes I'm very
optimistic I'm going to abandon you at
this point I'm going to jump off the ice
cream
but it's been a pleasure speaking with
you